es gibt noch eine andere wichtige
Debatte und da hat Herr Winkler ein
ähnliches Problem wie Kevin Kühnert mit
mit seinem Kanzler sie haben ein Problem
mit ihrem Parteichef der dieser Tage
laut nachdachte über Steuererhöhungen
und sie sagen wie kann das denn sein
ich glaube dass wir momentan keine
Debatte übersteuert Erhöhung brauchen
das hat zwei Gründe auf der einen Seite
müssen wir attraktive ausländische Fach
und Spitzenkräfte werden weil das sind
wir offensichtlich noch nicht in
Deutschland und auf der anderen Seite
sondern Debatte die relativ wenig
stattfindet in Deutschland müssen wir
auch aufpassen Fach und Spitzenkräfte in
Deutschland zu halten also ich habe mir
das mal beim Statistischen Bundesamt
angeschaut eine viertel Millionen
deutsche Staatsbürger pro Jahr wandern
aus
viele davon in Länder die deutlich
geringere Einkommensteuer haben und ich
würde sagen bevor wir
Anstrengung also die Einkommensteuer
erhöhen sollten über andere Dinge
nachdenken die die war bräuchten oder
die da jetzt gehen sind ja zum Teil
hochqualifizierte ki-spezialisten und
andere wir sind ja ziemlich gut
wenn es im Grundlagenforschung geht wenn
es um Ausbildung geht und dann sind wir
nicht in der Lage die Leute zu halten
Alexander
ich habe ja schon gesagt dass ich dieses
industriestrompapier der SPD gelesen
habe ich habe auch die Steuerpläne von
Friedrich Merz gelesen klingt ja sehr
streberhaften Fresse aber ich werde
dafür bezahlt und ich glaube dass sie
gegen einen propans Anreiten weil wenn
das so ist wie er merkt das
aufgeschrieben hat und er legt sich an
anderen Konzept vom Steuerzahler Bund
dann geht es um Leute die 1,2 Millionen
Euro im Jahr verstorben und also
Einkommen haben zu versteuerndes
Einkommen und da muss man auch als
Fachkraft schon ziemlich weit vorne sein
ja also das besondere bei diesem März
Konzept ist erklären
sollte man wissen seit über 20 Jahren
wird keine Steuerpolitik mehr gemacht
also Merkel hat das nicht gemacht in der
Scholz macht es nicht weil das immer
blockiert ist ja und das führt dazu dass
immer mehr Leute in Spitzensteuersatz
rutschen war nie geplant jetzt ist man
schon bei 1,3 oder 1,4 vom
Durchschnittsverdienst im
Spitzensteuersatz und das das kannst
nicht sein weil knapp über 60.000 ne ist
man also Bruttoeinkommen ist jemand
schon im spitzer passiert was ein echtes
Problem ist ganz lange wäre ein
Politiker mal rausgekommen hätte das
gefordert der wäre sofort weg gewesen
was ist so gekommen und es ist blockiert
weil die einen ebenen wollen und die
anderen sagen es darf nie auch nur
irgendein Steuersatz erhöht werden und
dass ich jetzt die CDU ausgerechnet
unter Friedrich Merz den Kopf macht in
der Opposition wie kann man das Auflösen
also wie können wir dahin kommen dass
wir den Spitzensteuersatz für einen
normale Leute viel viel später erst
kriegen lassen genau
die haben jetzt gesagt wir machen
drei Stufen also bis 100 ab 100.000 42%
300 000 45 % und dann eine dritte Stufe
ich glaube eine Million 48 % so und
dadurch haben sie nominell eine Erhöhung
des Spitzensteuersatzes nämlich diese 48
aber selbst die Zahlen nicht mehr
weil ja die abgeflacht werden in der
Mitte also sie zahlen ja nicht ab dem
ersten Euro den sie verdienen die 48%
sondern erst wenn sie da sind also sie
flachen das in der Mitte ab okay und
alle zahlen weniger sogar die oben außer
die über 1,2 Millionen im Jahr aber
es ist nur nominell höher so und wenn
die CDU damit in die Debatte geht und
zwar in eine koalitionsverhandlung mit
der SPD oder mit den Grünen könnte es
tatsächlich dazu kommen dass man da mal
irgendetwas macht und ich sage auch
gleich den großen Nachteil
ist nicht aufkommst neutral das heißt
wenn man das so machen würde wären 30
Milliarden Euro weg im Bundeshaushalt wo
man sich den Kopf machen müsste wo
kriegt man jetzt her also die
eigentliche Kritik müsste nicht sein die
48 für die ganz oben sondern wer soll es
bezahlen
würden sie das mittragen so eine Art von
Steuerreform
vom Grundkonstrukt her ist das was
Friedrich Merz ins Schaufenster gestellt
hat als anscheinend sein privatvorschlag
entspricht dem Steuerkonzept mit dem die
SPD jetzt bereits seit einigen Jahren
privatvorschlag was ist das noch
offensichtlich gibt es ja noch ein
bisschen was zu diskutieren in der CDU
also ich habe jetzt die Meinungsäußerung
der letzten Tage nicht so interpretiert
dass das Publikum schon auf den Stühlen
aber wenn Sie Ihren Passage nicht
verteidigen dann muss ich schon aus
Kommunisten Pflicht machen die haben
eine Fachkommission für neues
Grundsatzprogramm und da kommt das her
also wir haben schon darüber gesehen
eigentlich privat ist das jetzt wirklich
Friedrich Merzig lange genug und der
erste war draußen
und dann ist er mehr als erstmal geguckt
wer sich so beschwert und dann ist er
eingeschlagen
dass hier der spd-general sitzt und das
gut findet und der Chef der jungen
Millionen sagt nee das können wir nicht
machen
Bundestages selten so viel zitiert
worden wie in den letzten zwei Tagen wo
aller Leute 9 März Warnhinweise also aus
dem liberalkonservativen Spektrum
zugerufen haben er soll es sich Gedanken
machen dass er und ich jetzt dasselbe
Steuerkonzept
da ist es das aber B sollte er sich
nicht entmutigen lassen weil er ist ja
mit einer richtigen Erkenntnis auf der
Lauer richtigen Erkenntnis auf der Spur
es ist nicht nur so dass was die
einkommensteuertarife angeht seit Jahren
nichts gemacht worden ist sondern im
Gegenteil wenn man den Blickwinkel etwas
leitet in die Vergangenheit hat hier für
gerade was den Einkommensbereich angeht
ja eine andauernde Steuersenkung lange
Zeit stattgefunden also wir kamen
beizeiten von Helmut Kohlmann aus einem
Bereich da ist der höchste
Grenzsteuersatz in jemand zahlen konnte
in Deutschland bei 56 % gewesen
Steuersatz der höchste Grenzsteuersatz
jemand zahlen kann es ist
45%, das ist bei Singles die eine
viertel Millionen mehr klar haben da
kommen dann noch mal diese drei
Prozentpunkte am Ende oben drauf und wir
vertreten bereits seit einiger Zeit die
Auffassung konnten das leider noch nicht
in dieser Koalition durchsetzen auch
nicht in der davor mit der Union
vertreten die Auffassung ist man eine
einkommenssteuerreform machen sollte die
unten entlastet Spitzensteuersatz auch
deutlich später greifen lässt und dann
aber eben moderat auch bei höheren
Einkommen mehr reinholt das sind nicht
dieselben Tarifgrenzen am Ende wie er
merci vor Augen hat aber das
Grundprinzip ist dasselbe und wichtig
ist auch bei uns das ist
aufkommensneutral geschlagen diese Form
ins neutral wir schlagen diese Reform
nicht mit dem Ziel vor mehr Einnahmen
für den Bundeshaushalt zu generieren
sondern es handelt sich hier um einen
rein Eingriff der unter den
Einkommensarten von denen ganz oben den
5% nur Umverteilung zugunsten der
anderen vorn und das ist unser
Spitzen darf Herr März möchte die in der
Mitte entlasten und Zähne knirschen
nimmt er im Kauf das oben mehr gezahlt
werden muss richtig Herr Kühnert möchte
die ganz oben mehr bel und nimmt seine
Knirschen in Kauf das in der Mitte dafür
irgendwas
könnte man sich in einer Koalition
treffen deshalb bin ich ja dafür dass
diese Debatte anfängt wir sind auch in
der Welt gar nicht eigentlich nicht mit
Friedrich Merz in einer Koalition kann
ich Ihnen sagen
aber ich gebe zu dass auch bei uns in
der Redaktion der Welt Leute auf der
Position von Herrn Winkel sind die sagen
jede Steuererhöhung ist das Teufels und
damit fangen wir gar nicht erst an sage
ich gar nicht aber ich bin würde sagen
es muss da was passieren und deshalb ist
das eine politische Lockerungsübung aber
noch
nicht verstanden ich sag das gar nicht
das ist keine Steuererhöhung niemals
geben darf nur ich glaube bevor wir die
Steuern erhöhen
egal ob in der Mitte oben oder sonst wo
bevor wir die Steuern erhöhen müssen wir
auch mal schauen dass wir auf der
Ausgabenseite besser wirtschaften so
deswegen
verstehe ich ganz viele Diskussionen
nicht bevor ich doch den Leuten als
Bundesregierung sage ihr müsst mehr
zahlen schaue ich doch als
Bundesregierung erstmal selber wo kann
ich denn vielleicht einsparen was kann
ich denn vielleicht besser machen
wo würden sie anfangen also ich würde
vielleicht mal bei der Bundesregierung
selber anfangen die Bundesregierung hat
damit angefangen den Beamtenapparat der
Regierung und endlich aufzublenden es
gibt 43 Sonderbeauftragte der
Bundesregierung es gibt 37
Parlamentarische Staatssekretärin der
Bundesregierung beides Rekorde die haben
alle ihren Fahrer die haben alle im Büro
und bevor ich den Leuten sage ihr müsst
jetzt mehr zahlen würde aber bei mir
selber anfangen okay und sagen aber das
das ist nicht
Probleme
wirklich die die echt weil wenn ich Sie
richtig verstanden habe Herr Winkel
ihnen geht es ja um was ganz
grundsätzliches sie sagen dieser
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland ist
einfach nicht mehr wettbewerbsfähig
Arbeit ist zu teuer der Sozialstaat ist
zu teuer wir müssen attraktiv werden für
genau die Leute die wir eigentlich dann
brauchen und suchen die die tollen
attraktiv wir sind aktiv Spezialisten
beispielsweise die dann irgendwo
jenseits von 300.000 zum Beispiel
verdienen und das sieht man sieht ja was
mit denen passiert die gehen in die USA
wo sie weit niedrigere Steuersätze haben
und nebenbei noch besseres Wetter genau
so und jetzt machen sie zurecht naja
nenne noch mal ein paar Punkte wo der wo
du wirklich was wo du wirklich was
generieren kannst wo du wirklich
einsparen kannst meiner Meinung nach auf
der einen Seite bei der Energiepolitik
der Bundesregierung wir haben darüber
gesprochen
atomkraftventionieren mit Steuergeld auf
der anderen Seite das heizungsgesetz
über das ich auch noch mal gerne
sprechen würde wie viel staatlichen
Mittel da in die Förderung fließen also
da kann man auch eine Menge einsparen
indem man es einfach nicht macht
und dann ein dritter
transformationsfonds nicht aus dem
Kernhaushalt des Bundes ja ist doch egal
wo es herkommt es macht aber insgesamt
einfach keinen Sinn das Gesetz es macht
insgesamt keinen Sinn vor allem
klimapolitisch keinen Sinn weil deswegen
sollte man es nicht machen also das
heizungsgesetz ist ja man kann sich ja
fragen warum machen wir das eigentlich
so und jetzt sagt Robert Habeck
Klimaschutz okay jetzt kann man sich ja
mal fragen wie viel CO2 wird dadurch
eigentlich eingespart Dietmar Bart der
jetzt nicht in der Union ist hat das mal
die Bundesregierung gefragt und die
Bundesregierung hat gesagt naja wir
sparen durch das heizungsgesetz
kumuliert bis 2030 44 Millionen Tonnen
CO2 ein okay hört sich erstmal viel an
dann hat ein guter Freund von mir
Raphael salak mal ausgerechnet wie ist
das eigentlich im internationalen
Vergleich weil Klimaschutz ist ja nur
eine globale Aufgabe und keine nationale
Aufgabe und hat mal geschaut wie viel
imitiert China eigentlich an CO2 im Jahr
das sind 12,5 Milliarden Tonnen ja dann
können also das was wir insgesamt bis
2030 sparen imitiert China an einem Tag
das ist das heizungsgesetz so und dafür
gehen Milliarden Euro Steuergelder drauf
und wenn Sie mich fragen Winkel sagt
doch mal woher willst du die Kohle
nehmen dann ist das ein Beispiel wo ich
sage das werden mindestens mal 10
Milliarden Euro ich habe ihn also seit
einem halben Jahr sagt die Union habe
ich mit seinem heizungsgesetz das ganz
schlimm weil das wäre ein Verbotsgesetz
und man sollte statt verbieten lieber
fördern
und jetzt haben sie den habe ich soweit
dass er sein Gesetz irgendwie zu zwei
Drittel verschrottet hat und ein
fördergesetz geschrieben hat und jetzt
sagen Sie das ist aber zu teuer ich
glaube nicht dass die Union jemals
gesagt hat wir brauchen einen völlig
sinnloses Gesetz hinsichtlich des
Klimaschutzes und gehen dafür Milliarden
Steuergelder aus wir wollen es gab ja
schon ein heizungsgesetz dass die Union
mittragen
wir machen nicht ein neues Gesetz diese
Woche Freitag im deutschen Bunde
reformieren eines dass ich glaube nur 20
19 mit der Union eingeführt haben
übrigens ein Gesetz was genau ein Verbot
kennt das ist schon drin das Verbot von
besonders ineffizienten
älteren Ölheizung tatsächlich nach einer
gewissen Restlaufzeit rausgenommen
werden müssen und nur ganz kurz raus
Reis Gebote um mir mal das Wort des
letzten halben Jahres aufzugreifen
werden nach diesem Reform nicht drin
sein
ehrlich machen in der Diskussion
vor einiger Zeit hier Peter Altmaier das
war sehr interessant und der Wiese auf
etwas hin was in dieser ganzen
Diskussion für meine empfinden
tatsächlich auch zu kurz kommt weil es
einfach zum Protokollen zur Geschichte
dazu gehört der sagte es völlig egal wer
da gerade in der Regierung ist auch wenn
wir es werden wir die Union wir müssten
das auch machen
das ist besser
sie persönlich nicht im politischer
Verantwortung aber was machen sie sich
aber sehr schwer
ich mache mir keine schlanken Fuß
sondern ich sage ich schaue mir anmachen
ich schaue mir die Gesetze an die wir
machen und das Gesetz was die Ampel
plant ist klimapolitischen das ist doch
der ganze Hintergrund das
heizungsgesetzes ist klimapolitisch so
sinnlos dass wir uns das Geld lieber
sparen sollten und weil sie mich gefragt
haben wo kommen denn viele Milliarden
her wenn du nicht die Steuern erhöhen
willst was ja eine logischerweise ist
also sie sagen gar nicht machen genau
also
hier ein junger Mensch von 31 Jahren
sitzt also wenn ich eine Runde ein
Interesse daran haben müsste rein
theoretisch dass wir von diesem ganzen
co2-thema ein bisschen runterkommen und
sie beide das genau und ich sage eben
Klimaschutz ist ein globales Thema
nationales Thema mit diskutieren in
Deutschland Klimaschutz so als ob es in
deutsches Klima gäbe was an den
deutschen Grenzen enden würde
und will deswegen mit nationalen
Maßnahmen retten könnten und wenn sie
sagen wenn sie sagen naja wie wollen Sie
denn CO2 reduzieren dann sag ich ganz
einfach indem man die Kernkraftwerke
weiterlaufen lässt also ihre Lösung ist
einfach Atomkraft was heißt einfach
Atomkraft das ist so ein bisschen so ein
bisschen despektierlich aber nein
eine Gas und eine Ölheizung nicht mit
Strom
trotzdem fällig und dann sind wir wieder
in der förderfähre getroffen
sollen das führt dann konsequenterweise
ganz ganz vielen Dank das Problem dieser
China Vergleich hinführen wenn wir uns
wenn wir unsere Emission mit denen einer
Milliarde plus Menschen Nation ob es nun
China oder Indien ist vergleichen dann
können wir jeglichen Politik einsetzen
ob man ihn jetzt individuell für
erfolgsversprechend hält oder nicht
können wir einpacken weil das immer
nicht anstehen gegen das was in diesen
Volkswirtschaften anfällt das sind
Argumente die höher ich gelegentlich im
Bundestag aber von der Seite die sich
gar nicht für Klimaschutz interessieren
aber dieser Zeit tickt einfach wir haben
ein geltendes Klimaschutzgesetz das habt
ihr mit beschlossen cduismus
aus Kolumbien wo sie auch noch in
indigen Gebieten abgebaut wird aber das
was jetzt überhaupt keine Rolle gespielt
hat in der gesamten Diskussion war der
pädagogische Ansatz dieses Gesetzes den
dürfen wir nicht vergessen der und der
ist ja also man merkt die Absicht und
man ist verstimmt kann ich dazu nur
sagen denn das was eigentlich gemacht
werden soll ist es wird gehandelt bei
dem
emissionsintensiven Sektor Heizung ja
richtig aber das was Sie gesagt haben
dass sie Auswirkungen auf das globale
Klima nicht besonders groß ist sogar
richtig aber weshalb wir es trotzdem
machen ist einfach unser deutscher
pädagogischer Anspruch der Welt zu
zeigen wir sind die Vorreiter und bitte
macht das jetzt mal alles nach wir sind
die Schuhe Meister und das ist etwas ich
weiß nicht das ist eine ziemlich teuer
erkaufte pädagogische Vorbildwirkung
ist sondern es geht einfach darum
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher in
Deutschland die heute Foss jeder darf
ich jeder zweite Haushalt heizt mit Gas
und einer von vielen heizt mit Öl das
ist der Status Quo in Deutschland im
Jahr 2023 und diese Menschen haben im
vergangenen Jahr erlebt was für Risiken
nicht nur klimapolitisch sondern auch
was den Geldbeutel angeht stimmt in der
Nutzung von fossilen Energieträgern drin
liegt und wenn wir das jetzt schon
gesehen haben dann macht man sich gar
nicht vorstellen was in den unwegbarkeit
in den nächsten 5 10 20 Jahre passieren
wird
VerbraucherInnen
selber gemerkt und verstanden da muss
doch keinen keine Bundesregierung kommen
und sagen und jetzt erklären ihr euch
das mal und noch dazu der ganzen Welt
wie wir das jetzt mal am besten machen
das ist dieser Ansatz dieser
pädagogische Ansatz der die Bürger auch
in gewisser Weise entmündigt und sie im
Grunde genommen nicht auf Augenhöhe
ansprechen uns recht ist dann per se aus
ihrer Sicht in der Gesellschaft greife
ich immer zu Ordnungsrecht oder greife
ich vielleicht auch einfach mal zur
Selbsterkenntnis der Menschen das wäre
ja auch eine Variante ja gut also das
wird beim Klimaschutz nun bislang allein
auf selbst Erkenntnis setzen nicht an
den Punkt gekommen sind an dem wir sein
sollten ist glaube ich schon etwas von
der Gesellschaft
eigentlich eine sehr gute Überleitung
das Stichwort Bürger ist gerade gefallen
und ihnen geht's ja auch Frage wenn ich
Sie richtig verstanden habe um dieses
Verhältnis dass da entstanden ist Robin
Alexander argumentiert in der ähnliche
Richtung wie wir gleich hören werden
dieses Verhältnis sozusagen da ist der
Dienstleister Staat ja und Weg sehr sehr
große Erwartungshaltungen Stichwort
Bürgergeld die Frage sehr umstrittene
Frage und auch jeder Sendung häufig
lohnt sich eigentlich in diesem Land
Arbeit noch und gehören noch mal kurz
rein Friedrich Merz hat heute im
Bundestag so rausgedrückt bitteschön wir
würden das sogenannte Bürgergeld so
ausgestalten dass sich Arbeit mehr lohnt
als der Bezug von staatlichen
Transferleistungen
ich verstehe dass sie hier sehr nervös
reagieren aber das ist doch die Wahrheit
die wir im Augenblick sehen die Menschen
gehen nicht zurück in die Beschäftigung
weil sie sich ausrechnen können dass sie
mit staatlichen Transferleistungen am
Ende des Jahres mehr herausbekommen als
wenn sie in einer einfachen
Beschäftigung arbeiten und
Sozialversicherungsbeiträge und Steuern
bezahlen müssten nur damit das hier klar
ist weil ich das hier unter Koalition
höre das sind nicht die Menschen die zu
faul sind die Menschen können einfach
rechnen im Gegensatz zu manchen von
ihnen wie können rechnen
[Applaus]
recht nein und das ist jetzt auch keine
parteipolitische Frage sondern das ist
erstmal ganz nüchtern eine sachlich
falsche Darstellung ich habe ihm sehr
gut heute morgen zugehört bei seiner
Rede im Deutschen Bundestag und er hat
wie ich finde eine
Grenzüberschreitung gemacht die ich von
ihm bisher nicht gehört werden nämlich
nicht mehr gesagt die Leute empfinden es
so dass Arbeit sich nicht lohnt darüber
könnte man ja diskutieren oder über die
Größe von Abständen sondern er hat
gesagt es lohnt sich nicht arbeiten zu
gehen das heißt Tatsache dargestellt
dass Menschen die Transferleistung
kriegen mehr kriegen und das ist man
muss das so deutlich sagen einfach
wenn es sozusagen eins zu eins ist lohnt
es sich quasi nicht mehr das ist aber
auch nicht eins zu eins unser
Sozialstaat über den man diskutieren
kann in seiner ausgestalten man kann
über Prozentsätze frei betrinken man
kann über alles reden aber er ist vom
Grundkonstrukt her so aufgebaut das ist
immer auch die Bürger Geldreform im
letzten Jahr einen Anreiz hin zu
arbeiten gibt es gibt immer Zuverdienst
Freigrenzen also allein schon für die
Leute die im Bürgergeld
drin sind dass die was dazu verdienen
viele sind ja da in Arbeit vergessen wir
häufig in der Diskussion von den
erwachsenen Menschen im erwerbsfähigen
Alter die im bürgergeldbezug sind
arbeitet Arbeiten 20 Prozent das sind
Aufstocker die zahlen wir alle mit weil
die schlechte Löhne bei ihren
Arbeitgebern kriegen unter den
Alleinerziehenden dort ist es jeder
dritte also das ist schon verankert das
Prinzip da drin und es ist besonders das
muss ich schon auch dazu sagen besonders
possierlich wenn man so eine Diskussion
hört über den Wert der Arbeit von einer
Partei mit der wir jetzt acht Jahre
zusammen regiert haben und wo wir auf
taube Ohren gestoßen sind wenn es um die
Mindestlohn Einführung die
mindestlohnerhöhung die Einführung eines
Tarif treuegesetzes in Deutschland und
anderes mehr gesprochen haben ich habe
den Eindruck hier soll vor allem wieder
das gute alte Spiel Niedriglöhner gegen
transferleistungsbezieher gespielt
werden bei dem am Ende nicht der
Niedriglöhner mehr Geld hat sondern
einfach nur alle sich ein bisschen wohl
fühlen können an der sozialen
auseinandersetzen die eine Sicht der
Dinge wie geht ihre Sicht
also ich habe vor der Sendung nicht mit
Friedrich Merz sondern mit einer
Führungskraft in einem Jobcenter
gesprochen
und hat gesagt weil ich jetzt in der
Debatte glaube ich muss mal generell
vorsichtig sein weil das sind Menschen
die nicht viel Geld haben
und deswegen habe ich sie einfach
gefragt ja wie ist es ein bei Ihnen wie
sehen Sie die Reform der Ampel
und hat sie zu mir gesagt naja es gibt
durchaus auch positive Punkte aber es
gibt einen ganz großes Problem
wie schaffen wir eine Verbindlichkeit in
einem Sozialstaat wenn also der
Steuerzahler durch erarbeitetes Geld
andere Menschen finanziert die gerade
nicht arbeiten so und diese
Verbindlichkeit die hat eben die Ampel
mehr oder weniger abgeschafft indem sie
gesagt hat naja die
Sanktionsmöglichkeiten die es vorher gab
die wollen wir nicht mehr
die Union hat dann gesagt im Bundesrat
hat sich damit am Ende des Tages ein
bisschen durchgesetzt nicht genug aber
sie hat sich stückweise durchgesetzt hat
gesagt naja
Menschen die vom Staat leben vom
steuerzahlerleben den muss es auch da
muss es auch sozusagen in Ordnung sein
wenn man sagt du musst eine zumutbare
Arbeit annehmen so und diese
Führungskraft hat mir eben gesagt naja
also das kratzt ehrlich gab
ehrlicherweise schon an den Kollegen
wenn Leute dann zum Jobcenter kommen die
ja wissen dass es keine großen
Sanktionen gibt wenn sie zumutbare
Arbeit nicht annehmen und deswegen hat
Friedrich Merz völlig recht mit dem was
er gesagt hat und ich will das noch
ergänzen wir müssen das Ziel gerichtet
machen beim Bürgergeld ich würde zum
Beispiel sagen die Erhöhung geht für
Alleinerziehende mit Kinder in Ordnung
aber es geht ja auch immer
alleinstehende
alleinstehende Bürgergeld Empfänger
haben in den letzten zwei Jahren von
2022 Hartz IV bis zum ersten ersten 24
Bürgergeld eine Erhöhung um über 25%
bekommen
unter mal 12 Prozent und da darf man
sich ehrlicherweise schon fragen und das
fragen sich auch viele Leute ja und
deswegen hat Friedrich Merz damit auch
völlig Recht da fragen sich viele Leute
ist das denn wirklich gerecht und ich
mache dann ein großes Fragezeichen
hinter und deswegen stimme ich Friedrich
Merz da völlig zu und deswegen bin ich
da bei meinem Ausgangs Statement
wir brauchen schwierige Entscheidung
auch im Sozialstaat und deswegen ist das
was wir mit der Agenda 2010 damals
gemacht haben richtig und das was die
Ampel heute macht leider falsch
Alexander wie geht ihre Analyse ich habe
sie vorhin zitiert sie sagten wenn man
ungefähr sind glaube ich 1,7 Millionen
Menschen in Hartz IV oder Bürger Geld
hat gleichzeitig jedes Jahr Rekord
Einwanderung und auf der anderen Seite
ungefähr genauso viele nämlich knapp
zwei Millionen offene Stellen die wir
nicht besetzt kriegen selbst stellen die
keine große Qualifikation erfordern wir
alle kennen Situationen an Flughäfen und
anderes sagen
dann muss man als Staat sagen oder
könnte man sich dem Gedanken nähern dass
da irgendetwas schief läuft was läuft da
schief das ist ja der große Unterschied
zur Zeit der Agenda 2010 der Agenda
wurde ja gemacht in der Zeit der
Massenarbeitslosigkeit so das ist jetzt
nicht das Problem sondern man hat
Leute die langfristig arbeitslos sind
und man hat eine Menge offener Stellen
und nicht nur stellen meine
Qualifikation braucht sondern auch ganz
simple Sachen und und da ist etwas was
austariert werden muss das gibt zwei
sozusagen Vorurteile das eine ist die
sind alle faul das natürlich Quatsch
aber natürlich gibt es auch Milieus die
sich darin einrichten und die auch
kombinieren mit
Schwarzarbeit oder mit nebenbei also und
das ist immer und das ist gar keine
moralische Frage es ist immer schwierig
der Übergang ja also wenn man das wird
ja immer über diese Zuverdienst Dinge so
gerungen ja also wenn man was dazu
verdient wie viel muss man abgeben ja
und dieser Übergang in das erwerben ist
schwierig so und natürlich ist das so
zweimal zwölf Prozent jetzt wir haben
das ja vorgerechnet und die Regierung
hat ja geguckt dass die Löhne nicht
dramatisch gestiegen sind also diese
inflationsprämie die Regierung erfunden
hat also das sind Arbeitgeber 3000 Euro
steuerfrei zahlen kann aber nur einmalig
war ja die Idee nicht in eine Lohn
Preisspirale zu kommen beziehungsweise
sehr gute Idee nur dann ist es natürlich
schon ein Problem wenn man sagt die
Löhne sollen nicht unbedingt massiv
hochsteigen aus guten Gründen wenn die
Sozialleistungen so massiv steigen das
ist ein objektives Problem das heißt es
ist gar kein Werturteil über diese
Menschen aber das Problem ist da und ich
finde dass sie Ampel ist verschärft auch
in ihrer Semantik also
Bürgergeld ja also ich verstehe dass man
den Leuten nicht Sozialhilfe sagen muss
aber der der Fokus verschiebt sich von
der Erwartung wir helfen jemanden in Not
zu es steht eigentlich jedem Zug und die
garantieren etwas
kindergrundlage in Deutschland ist die
rechtsprechungsverfassungsgerichts wir
haben den Begriff nicht aus Spaß
ausgetauscht und Kinder Grundsicherung
ist dasselbe also sie haben eine kann
man sie immer sagen sind nur Worte aber
sie haben eine semantische Verschiebung
in die erste Sicherheit kommt nicht mehr
von den Eltern sondern kommt vom Staat
und dahinter gibt es schon eine
Vorstellung von etwas wie
bedingungslosen Grundeinkommen also dass
wir eine Idealzustand kommen könnten wo
jeder erstmal ein basiseinkommen vom
Staat hat und nur wenn er sozusagen Bock
hat sich selbst verwirklichen will oder
so dann so und das ist schon eine
Vorstellung mit der wir glaube ich nicht
weit kommen und die wird in grün und
Teilen der SPD immer noch kultivieren
also einen schönen das kann ich weiter
ausführen die das bedingungslose
Grundeinkommen wird in der SPD nicht
ventiliert und verfolgt von irgendwem
aber es ist auf eine Art und Weise
Realität geworden nein ich habe so eben
schon gesagt das ist die Rechtsprechung
einfach was die Grundsicherung in
Deutschland wie auch immer man sie dann
am Ende nennt angeht es gibt ein
Existenzminimum was in Deutschland zu
definieren ist ein komplexes Verfahren
was da alles reinkommt genau und das ist
auch nicht zu relativieren das ist das
was unser Grundgesetz meint die Würde
des Menschen ist unantastbar ja man kann
sagen egal wie unkooperativ sich jemand
verhält sich aber das an unserer Welt
und Menschenbild in Deutschland ist so
dass keine Situationen entstehen kann in
der wir jemanden in der Gosse am Ende
liegen lassen um es so deutlich
auszusprechen ist die Rechtsprechung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts in Deutschland
und auf dieser Grundlage dessen was zu
einer
mindestteil habe am gesellschaftlichen
Leben dazugehört wird das jährlich neu
berechnet wir haben das jetzt ein
bisschen geändert damit nämlich die
Entwicklungen bei der Inflation haben
wir letztes Jahr gemerkt sich nicht
anderthalb Jahre später da haben die
Leute dann auch nichts mehr von dem
Regelsatz niederschlagen sondern schnell
die Berechnung basiert wenn jetzt so
eine Anpassung kommt im Bürgergeld wie
sehen nächstes Jahr ansteht zu 70
Prozent auf Grundlage der allgemeinen
Preisentwicklung und zu 30% auf
Grundlage der Lohnentwicklung so gar
keine politische Entscheidung da sitzen
nicht Scholz Habeck und Lindner und
würfeln aus wie sehr das Bürgergeld
steigt sondern das ist ein
berechnungsmatrix die dahinter gelegt
ist und unser Job das ist dafür zu
sorgen dass auf dem anderen Ende bei den
unteren Lohngruppen Konditionen bestehen
bei denen die auch hochgehen deswegen
haben wir den Mindestlohn im vergangenen
Jahr erhöht und deswegen brauchen 12
Euro auf 12 Euro
40 41 und das ist okay wenig ja und im
nächsten Jahr auf 12,80 €, 82 glaube ich
und das ist zu wenig hier hat sich die
Arbeitgeberseite
also wo ich sozusagen ihre ich ich das
ist eine politische Frage die sie
stellen und die lohnt es sich auch zu
diskutieren finde ich wer arbeitet hat
mehr raus es ist sehr individuell die
Frage zu beantworten ab wann man findet
dass die Arbeitskraft die man einsetzt
die Mühen die man auf sich nimmt seine
körperlichen und geistigen Kapazitäten
die man in die Arbeit einbringt ab wann
das nicht mehr in einem angemessenen
Verhältnis steht und da lohnt es sich
ständig angemessenen Verhältnis ich
verstehe ganz viele Leute im
Niedriglohnbereich die sagen für wenige
hundert Euro mehr die ich am Ende raus
habe finde ich mich nicht gerecht
behandelt in dieser Gesellschaft ich
finde aber in allem was anderes aber der
Sozialdemokrat antwortet ihn da drauf
ganz klar dafür wollen wir starke
Gewerkschaften in funktionierenden
sozialpartnerschaften in Deutschland die
wollen wir unterstützen mit Tarif teures
Gesetz und anderem weil sie können gute
Abschlüsse rausarbeiten sie haben jetzt
ausgerechnet 12% geht's hoch nächstes
Jahr beim Bürgergeld und jetzt guckt
natürlich jeder Beschäftigte mir genau
durchschnittliche Lohnsteigerung die
durchschnittliche Steigerung und Lehrer
die Arbeiten geht
ich kann ihnen zu Schlüssen jetzt aus
dem ersten halben Kollegen sagen also
zum Beispiel Müllwerker der im
Tarifvertrag des öffentlichen Dienstes
mit ein paar Jahren dabei hat 14,1
bisschen Prozent jetzt in der von Verdi
ausgehandelten Runde gehabt und andere
Gewerkschaften haben noch besser fast
verhandelt die haben nämlich siehe die
Eisenbahn und verkehrsgewerkschaften
Tarifabschluss gemacht in der gar nicht
prozentual nach Lohngruppen gegangen
wurde sondern die haben besonders für
die untersten Lohngruppen in absoluten
Eurozahlen was rausgeholt 410 € geht's
bei allen waren Beschäftigten jetzt hoch
ich glaube 340 sind es bei der Post das
heißt für die untersten Lohngruppen dort
definitiv dass die deutlich mehr an Lohn
zu wachsen in diesem und im nächsten
Jahr raus haben als es die Menschen im
Leistungsbezug haben werden und so
funktioniert dann soziale Geistlichkeit
auf einem guten Arbeitsmarkt ganz ganz
tief einsteigen sollten wir vielleicht
nicht tun aber nur zwei sozusagen
Beispiel an dem was man festmachen
können eine Familie mit zwei Kindern
verdienen im Niedriglohnbereich
ja mindestlohnbereich die haben das
haben ganz viele Menschen schon
schlauere Menschen als ich berechnet die
haben am Ende des Monats faktisch nicht
mehr als jemand der Bürger Geld bekommt
wahrscheinlich bevor wir das falsch das
kommt sehr auf die Konstellation an und
da muss ich Ihnen jetzt die gegenüber
haben diese Leute dann sozusagen haben
die schon ihre Möglichkeiten
Kinderzuschlag in Anspruch zu nehmen
Wohngeld in Anspruch zu nehmen Anspruch
wann soll das machen wann sollen die das
machen das ist nämlich genau der Punkt
das sind zwei Menschen die gehen beide
morgens aus dem Haus und ich kenne viele
solche Menschen und die Arbeiten richtig
richtig und deswegen hat er Alexander so
recht wenn er sagt die sind nicht faul
sein die arbeiten exakt die kommen nach
Hause die kümmern sich um die Kinder
dann sitzt da noch jemand der braucht
jetzt irgendwie Hilfe bei den
Hausaufgaben ja dann sagt noch
irgendjemand hast du eigentlich an den
Sport gedacht dann sagt irgendjemand
hast du irgendwas eingekauft kannst du
mal schnell kochen und dann fällst du
irgendwann nachdem du vielleicht das
noch geschafft hast die gute Nacht
Geschichte vorzulesen ja komplett fertig
abends um 10 Uhr ins Bett ja meine Frage
ist wann geht der jetzt noch mal morgens
um 7 Uhr los oder noch früher und
beantragt bei diversen Behörden Zusatz
für
Kindergeld Zusatzgeld für Wohnen
Zusatzgeld für heizungsweiter und wo
geht er überhaupt hin in im Hoch
digitalisierten Land Deutschland wo geht
der überhaupt hin ja weil sie verstehen
mein Punkt absolut und der zweite Punkt
ist der zweite Punkt ist viele dieser
Menschen haben einen stolz ja und die
sind stolz auf ihre Unabhängigkeit die
sind stolz darauf nicht vom Staat leben
zu müssen und nicht zu wollen diesen
Leuten muten Sie zu dass sie erst dann
etwas mehr in der Tasche haben wenn sie
noch anfangen beim Start bitte bitte
bitte zu machen kannst du das in Ordnung
die ganze Beschreibung ist richtig und
auch das Empfinden dass sie da bei
äußern das teile ich ganz genau so aber
jetzt gibt es eine Verkennung in ihrer
Beschreibung den Lohn außerdem
Mindestlohn setzt in Deutschland nicht
der Staat das wäre also findet das Leute
und die gibt's zu Hause in unserem Land
die hart und viel arbeiten gehen
manchmal sogar ein paar Beziehungen mit
zwei Vollzeit Einkommen dass die mit zu
wenig nach Hause gehen da muss dann
schon auch die Frage an die Arbeitgeber
in unserem Land gerichtet werden wie das
sein kann das in ihren Betrieben
Menschen arbeiten die trotz
Vollzeitbeschäftigung mit einem Lohn
nach Hause gehen bei dem es nicht
funktioniert wir sind nicht stolz darauf
das kommt jetzt dreimal so viele
Haushalte haben die anspruchsvermächtigt
sind in dem Wohngeld kommt noch was für
verändert haben aber wir füllen dort
eine Lücke wie auch bei den Aufstockern
und beim Kinderzuschlag den uns der
Arbeitsmarkt wie wir ihn vorfinden
gelassen haben und wenn die SPD den
Mindestlohn nicht eingeführt und erhöht
hätte würden wir nicht über ein paar
Millionen Leute sprechen sondern über
zig Millionen Leute im Land die das
betrifft also stellen Sie die frage
jemanden vom Hotel und
Gaststättenverband beispielsweise und
von anderen
Sektor auch beschäftigen diese Leute
machen sich ja auch nicht alle einfach
ne das ist ja auch sehr pauschal ich
finde bei der Kinder Grundsicherung was
wirklich interessant ist ist doch das
damit ein Wechsel im System verbunden
ist
nämlich es stellt sich heraus dass
Großteil der Leute den Anspruch hatten
für für Kind was vom anzukriegen das
nicht beantragt haben
und unser manche Leistung zwei Drittel
der Anschluss genau und jetzt baut die
Regierung ein neues System dass die der
Staat sozusagen präventiv auf die Leute
zugeht und wir haben mal bei uns bei der
Welt den Interview der das machen muss
dass der Chef das heißt der
Familienkasse bisher und der sagt wenn
wir fertig sind dann schicken wir den
Leuten aufs Handy eine Push also die
kriegen auf ihr Handy sonst so eine Push
SMS hier musst du nur noch drücken damit
du dein Geld bekommst und das finde ich
auch vom vom ganzen Menschenbild
wahnsinnig interessant also ich komme
aus dem Ruhrgebiet meine Mutter war
Hauptschule darin damals war es noch so
dass viele Lehrer Familien ermuntern
mussten aktiv was zu beantragen das noch
gerade in heute wo man sagen prekären
Lebensverhältnissen sowas gab ich hole
nichts von Amt genau so und das hat sich
jetzt soweit gedreht dass der Staat
sozusagen Wege ausdenkt seine eigene
Bürokratie zu überspielen mit Technik
und ich will das gar nicht realisieren
ich finde das einfach nur Interesse so
und das ist schon interessant aber
eingefädelt wurde das Ganze doch von
hinten durch die Brust und diese diese
gesamte Kinder Grundsicherung die
wirklich etwas Gutes beinhaltet nämlich
alles in einer Hand die Leute müssen
nicht bitten sondern sie bekommen es
wenn Sie bestimmte Kriterien erfüllen
und so weiter das und die Leistung die
angeboten wird wird dadurch auch
abgerufen das ist ja erstmal eine völlig
nachvollziehbare und richtige und und
auch gescheite Angelegenheit
eingefädelt wurde das Ganze mit einem
Irrsinns hohen Betrag nämlich 12
Milliarden wir landen jetzt bei 2,4
Milliarden die Differenz wird irgendwie
überhaupt nicht kommuniziert diese an
der anfangsbetrag von zwölf Milliarden
wurde auch nicht kommuniziert da hat
Frau Haus bis heute nicht dargelegt was
sie eigentlich damit meinte und das was
die große Hoffnung ist das jetzt mal
entbürokratisiert wird
da warte ich noch drauf auf das wirklich
der Fall sein wird gedacht ist es gut
wenn es so umgesetzt wird wäre es prima
ja ich finde der der Staat spielt immer
eine aktive Rolle also zum Beispiel
deswegen habe ich von den Begriff
Dienstleister statt benutzt also das
große Problem für Kinderarmut in unserem
Land ist die Trennung der Eltern das ist
völlig eindeutig statistisch und da kann
ein Staat natürlich nichts machen aber
die Idee als als Staat solche Dinge so
präventiv abzufangen dass sie keinen
Unterschied mehr machen und das geht ja
ein bisschen in die Mittelschicht also
denken wir
Rechtsanspruch auf Kita Platz also ich
kann als Eltern beim Staat einklagen
dass ich jemand und mein Kind kümmert
ich glaube das ist eine Idee gar nicht
funktioniert haben wir ja bei Corona
gesehen kommt die Pandemie will man denn
da verklagen ist am Ende fällt man doch
auf die Familie zurück aber dass der
Staat immer mehr in dieses oder selbst
heizungsgesetz also ich meine wir haben
am Ende gesprochen
über Subventionen von
70%, ist zu plus also dann noch andere
Dinge im Raum und das wir reden ja immer
noch über Leute die Eigentum haben und
werden Eigentum aufgewertet wird ja also
die Idee dass der Staat sozusagen nicht
nur in der Not zugreift und dich
irgendwie was hätte sondern dein Status
schützt auf ganz vielen Ebenen